foreign
[Music]
S I know it's been a while but I just
had something on my mind and I wanted to
make somewhat of a theoretical video on
understanding programming because I
think a lot of people kind of get stuck
in this phase of just not conceptually
understanding how programming and
computers work and this is something you
will start to understand if you go
through like computer science courses
and start learning binary math and a
little bit about machine code and that
sort of thing but it's not it doesn't
really get explained at the most basic
fundamental level too often and this is
something you need to understand in
order to often develop new features or
come up with things on the fly or be
creative with programming and I'm not
saying you can't do that otherwise but
it it helps to start thinking of this
like Legos or building blocks and you've
probably heard that a lot but I actually
mean that at an even lower level like uh
we all probably all heard that you know
computer science is basically in
computer programming is basically
messing with binary bits at the lowest
level you're just you're just turning
things on and off and going through
little logical switches so
what you can do is you can take that
very conceptually I don't know if that's
a word and apply that in a way that
allows you to build features and it
doesn't really matter what language it
doesn't matter what framework that's the
really cool thing about this is uh all
the above abstractions of what's the
latest Trend what editor you're using
all that none of that really matters all
that much uh if at all really I mean it
can help with your workflow once you're
going but as far as getting an actual
understanding and kind of coming up with
the creative ability to actually
Implement things none of that really
does anything for you so I it's just it
kind of I I'll say annoys me to go on
forums and posts and and just see so
many people going on and on about uh
just like little nuances of of things
that aren't really related to
programming but they seem to try to make
it like a main topic like uh you know
just about now
what keyboard you're using or what mouse
or Vim versus emacs or what hotkeys you
use and all just all this like random
little things and you know all that's
fine and everything really but it's
that's more of an aesthetic thing and it
really has nothing to do with uh
computer science and you well I'm saying
computer science kind of vaguely I kind
of mean like creative programming and
coming up with your own programs and one
of the reasons I wanted to give this
sort of talk this isn't totally off the
cuff talk to I don't have notes uh
nothing like that so I'm just just
winging it so maybe that'll make it
interesting maybe that'll make it
confusing I guess we'll see I wanted to
get this out there because one of the
things I'm going to do pretty soon is
talk more about application development
I think that needs a bit of a background
talk about uh just kind of ignoring a
lot of this
um
we'll say software that is sort of
irrelevant to actual programming but
it's made mainstream
so I'm going to put up some random it's
kind of random visuals and uh and just
talk about a few things here and
hopefully that helps some people get
started or understand things that they
might have
kind of been at a barrier with or not
really sure how to address because I
feel like some of these things were
definitely affecting me when I started
because I was always looking for the
right tutorial to do exactly what I
wanted to do or the right framework to
do exactly what I wanted to do or the
right program and to just kind of be
able to think about it in a different
way where you no longer need to find the
perfect answer but know how to formulate
it yourself is a really huge step and
I'm not even saying you're necessarily
going to come up with the exact answer
but just to be able to start ballparking
these answers and start kind of
understanding how you would begin to
even come up with a proper solution
without someone walking you through it
is is huge and it can make a big
difference in your career and your life
and what you can come up with and what
you can build transitioning to the scene
you're kind of putting up some
semi-random background not necessarily
totally related but just to give you
guys something to look at other than my
face and me talking and uh maybe a
little additional stimulation if you
will some might change this every once
in a while but also this is going to
kind of work to jog my mind and and
maybe talk a little bit better if I feel
like I'm getting stuck all right so
let's go back to thinking of it like
building blocks and Legos now you might
already have heard this a million times
because it kind of is that but you might
think of it as like okay I have this
programming language I like maybe C plus
plus maybe JavaScript maybe Python and
you start looking at things like okay
what libraries do I have available what
does this language have to offer and you
might try to come up with ideas or
Solutions based on that and I think that
is mostly improper because the better or
more real way to think about problems is
to think about how they can be
structured from the ground up I'm going
to try to give you an example okay so if
you think about like
think of a problem maybe an abstract
problem like how can we build for
example how can we build a brick wall
just like a literal brick wall you know
and how do we put a window in it right
if you think of that sort of problem all
right and then you might think okay
um because I you know I have a video
game I'm making for example and I want
to make a brick wall and I want it to
have Windows but I want to be able to
dynamically put that window in a
different spot and you might think okay
I'll open up blender I'm going to start
building assets to do that and then
maybe I'll just like load different
assets for the different places I want
the window and that is a ton of data I
mean you've got these object files
you're going to load in and you're gonna
you know you're gonna have a bunch of
different ones and you're gonna swap
them out on the Fly you got load times
you got loaders you're going to have
this giant just a huge it's just gonna
take a lot of space and a lot of
computational power to load and unload
and and do all this stuff just to make a
wall with one window in a different spot
or you could think about it from a more
ground up standpoint and think ones and
zeros
uh how would you do that that's kind of
simple if you think about it and like
yeah in a way that you could say okay
well let's just make a whole bunch of
ones and zeros and everywhere there's a
one
we'll have the wall be solid and
anywhere there's a zero we'll have it be
an empty space all right this is just
the simplest example I could think of
and with that way you could you could
literally just put in a bunch of ones
and zeros or a binary data structure and
uh and load that in and then have that
show the wall and anywhere there's zero
it's a window it's an open spot and now
you've just saved a ton of space because
you could uh rather than loading in
assets all the time you probably load in
like I don't know if you're doing
Graphics or something you might have two
textures but uh you know in the spots
where it's empty you don't show the
texture and it's just see-through and
otherwise you you do show it and it's
really that simple you don't have to
make a bunch of different assets you
don't have to load and unload you just
kind of like shift it around a little
bit and your computer will visualize it
properly that might be a little too
abstract but just you know if you can
just think about it as like one one is a
solid spot and zero is a not solid spot
it's that simple it's a very simple
thing and you can do that with most
problems when you break them down and
that's it's all about breaking it down
because things get really complicated at
times and uh you know there's all these
Concepts you need to understand and and
things like that and most of those are
somewhat irrelevant a lot of times you
know when you break it down and really
really analyze it
was you know this this goes for a lot of
a lot of different things you could say
for example if you just want something
to move you could say that when it's a
one or you know not zero it's moving or
when it's a zero it's stationary and
that's it you've got two bits and you've
got movement rather than
uh going through a whole giant structure
of something that's provided to you of
how to make movement now obviously you
could do more with it than that but
that's what you got to start thinking
about so what could you do with two bits
you could move or not move or you could
go forward or backwards but you couldn't
stop so you add another bit to do
another thing you know three bits you
could go forward backwards or stop add
another bit now you can jump so with
four bits you could get four full
movement and that's that's a pretty
small amount of data to do movement
because if you look at like I don't know
any game engine unreal Unity or
something and you look at okay I just
want to move what do I got to do you get
and you get all their structure of stuff
and it's basically a really really large
uh sizable amount of data and structures
and framework I'll do a little bit of
movement but when you break it down in
your head you can think in ways where
it's like wait I could do all this with
just four bits
you know and it's basically you know
that's toggling States so of course you
would have to program around them those
States
um like when this bits one move forward
okay how has moved forward work sure you
got to program that in but uh you got it
boiled down to a very very simple form
and that's really what I mean by all
this is just kind of understanding how
to boil things down to a really simple
logical form because when it comes down
to it that's ultimately how computers
work is in these very very very simple
forms so it's I think it's very
important to learn how to think like
that when you're building stuff because
that's where often the creative juices
stem from all right because you've got
these really basic States and then you
put algorithms around these state-based
things and now I'm not saying that's how
you always do it or that's how you
always should do it or anything like
that I'm just saying that is the
simplest form that has kind of done on
me for making stuff so that's often how
I uh I'll say regress to thinking when
I'm presented with a really complicated
problem that I need to solve is I just
break it down to some really simple form
like okay I need to move forward how the
heck do I move forward well you're
either moving forward or not so one bit
and you could kind of determine that and
then what do you do when it's on and
then you kind of make an algorithm based
on that you know in a game or something
you're going to have like a vector
Direction so you just gotta figure out
that direction say okay when this bit is
one apply this algorithm to whatever and
that's it and when it's not one you stop
and you can just do that across the line
and you can kind of apply that to almost
anything like
I don't know think of an example I could
probably break it down you might be able
to too and that's great practice to
think of some little problem and think
about how you can break it down and
often you'll you'll come to understand
that when you learn other things that
they often stem from this like
trying to think of a great example here
but like even as far as uh Lexing and
parsing and compilers now I'm not like a
compiler expert or anything but
one of the things it does
um I believe it's the is it the parser
or the lexer I always get those mixed up
like I said I'm not a compiler expert I
need to study it more but first you know
you you basically scan the text file and
see what's in it and all that is is
looking at little things and comparing
them it's like is there comma here is
there a semicolon what what uh character
are we looking at it's just a lot of
comparisons and determining if it's
right or wrong or if it fits or doesn't
fit and you can break that down into
kind of a binary thinking form and
that'll help you understand it because
you might say Okay I want it to maybe
I'm making my own compiler and I want to
understand this line of code uh
specifically just think of any line of
code maybe maybe you'll say like integer
x equals five
so you want it to be able to read
integer
and determine that that's either a real
thing either valid or not valid and how
do you determine that you look at what
came before it was that valid or not
valid so one or zero there and then you
look at the word integer was that valid
or not valid a one or a zero there and
then you look at the next part it might
be a variable name is that valid or not
valid another one or a zero there and
then you might have a symbol like an
equal sign is that valid a one or a zero
there and you just keep going down the
line like that and it's all just ones
and zeros and
and you know to logically build that
structure is what comes next because you
still have to think of this in a way of
kind of like a sequential is this valid
or not valid and it's just all ones and
zeros and you've got to determine what
happens in these different states like
uh okay I come to another point and when
it's not valid here what happens and
when it is valid here we continue as
normal and if you know there's certain
cases you come to uh where special
things might happen and that's that's
where it usually goes down to some
algorithm and creating more structures
of binary stuff now obviously this is
really like uh complicated and gonna
overwhelm your mind after a while and
you can't like fully build something
like this but you can logically think
through little problems this way and
anyways that's kind of how I do it a lot
of times when I'm stuck is I just very
logically step through these little
problems and it's all binary thinking
basically there's no real Midway Point
there's no like this kind of works with
computers and math and science it's
either it works or it doesn't there's no
in between and because all the in
between is also either well it's either
depending on the case it's either going
to be good enough or which is once again
a one or not good enough which is a zero
you could flip those if you want I'm
using one as success and uh zero is not
but you could do it the other way you
know you could say zero success or one
is not but you have to be clear about
that okay so that's like the main thing
I really just wanted to talk about and
just kind of put out there
is just this ability to kind of do this
conceptual thinking thing when you're
programming and to forget about all
these Frameworks and forget about all
these little things and all these bads
and what people are saying on
programming forums it's none of that
really matters all that much and in
terms of actually like getting work done
and actually getting your program
working how you want so
yeah I I don't know what I'll say about
I guess leave questions down below if
you want
um I am still active I know I don't make
very many videos I've just been really
busy with other things I got several
projects going on most of my projects
are private these days so I just don't
have much to share with the public but I
will at some point I've got a few things
cooking yeah I guess that's it all right
I'll see you guys the next one have a
good one peace out
[Music]
thank you